the Democratic Party psychotic
anti-trump rage it knows zero bounds and
tonight Nadler Pelosi and company well
they want the Attorney General of the
United States to actually break the law
or they're going to hold him in contempt
that's how twisted they've now become
Democrats want bar to reveal secret
grand jury information from the Muller
report or he'll face charges from
Congress if he did it it's illegal is a
federal violation under Rule 6 e to
reveal grand jury information their
lawmaker shouldn't they know this now
let's be very clear about where we are
with this as we speak a full completely
unredacted copy of the rollo report is
available right now but top Democrats to
view with only two full and seven
partial lines redacted that's it that
protect grand jury information as
pursuant to the federal law now neither
Nadler nor Pelosi or any other Democrat
for that matter have ever bothered to
view the report so all of what this is
is a circus it is a sideshow a total act
and it's just more lies as I have said
the Muller issue is over it is done it
is finished this that remains is merely
noise and recently congressman Hank
Johnson accidentally well stumbled on
the truth and spilled the beans and
admitted what this is really all about
we're moment of clarity take a look this
is all part of a cover-up and it is up
to this committee to ensure that we get
that report because we have lawful
responsibilities constitutional
responsibilities to to engage in one of
which is possibly impeachment how can we
impeach without getting the documents
okay it's pretty obvious the subpoena
and subsequent contempt boat just a
blatant political game a circus from a
group of well people who have conned the
American people for years with lies and
conspiracy theories
justise it means nothing to them look at
how the top Democrats reacted in 2012
when Obama's self-proclaimed wing man
Attorney General Eric Holder was held in
contempt after refusing to turn over
scores of subpoenaed documents related
to the Fast & Furious scandal by the way
a scandal where Americans and others
actually died because of their stupidity
but congressman Nadler rage he tweeted
against the very thought of a contempt
ruling in that case quote just join the
hashtag walk out of the house chamber to
protest the shameful politically
motivated GOP vote holding the AG holder
in contempt he deserves it now this from
the very same person had just voted to
hold o AG bar in contempt
why for not releasing two lines that he
must
he's mandated by law legally protected
grand jury information your hypocrisy
reeks and it wasn't just Nadler it's the
whole bunch of lunatics that is known as
the modern-day extreme radical
Democratic Socialist Party let's take a
look to bring this contempt of Congress
against the Attorney General the
Republicans are contemptible the rush
that they are putting on it is just an
explicable what are they doing what are
they doing having people want jobs
they're going on witch hunts the
Republican majority intends to bring a
contempt resolution to the floor against
the Attorney General to say that this is
a terrible use of Congress's power and
time is an understatement this is not
about the facts this is about politics
they have not found any evidence that
this Attorney General was hiding
anything that he had lied to anybody
they still do not have any facts to
support this ill legitimate
investigation to our Republican
colleagues shame on you shame on you
shame on you shame on you oh my yeah
it's like they are what are we gonna
rant today selective moral outrage it's
pretty much the Democrats party's
favorite tool fury over Cavanaugh
nothing over the allegations of violent
rape and violent sexual assault against
the Democratic lieutenant governor of
Virginia indignation over a Covington
high school student who actually was
perfect in a response in one of the most
difficult situations why he was wearing
a red Magga hat let's just bludgeon the
sixteen-year-old kid nothing more than a
yawn over the governor the Attorney
General of Virginia dressing up Oh in
blackface they are apocalyptic panic
over climate change but they have no
problem flying in and out of their
private jet headquarters and riding
around in their massive SUVs with oh
let's see people that guard them with
guns that we are not allowed to have and
let's not forget anger from the 1% from
multi-millionaire who calls himself a
socialist yeah that guy and worst of all
is the Selective moral outrage
surrounding so-called Russia collusion
because for two and a half years
Democrats their buddies in the media mob
they perpetuated nothing but lies
conspiracy theories a total hoax on the
American people
all while totally ignoring real
collusion right in front of their eyes
and as we all know by now Hillary
Clinton bought and paid for yeah
Russian lies using a foreign spy putting
together a document that he doesn't even
stand by with propaganda misinformation
lies leaked to the press why to help rig
the election in Hillary's favor
did I say with Russian lies in New York
Times suggesting that this was actually
part of a Russian disinformation
campaign all along and that didn't stop
the phony dossier from being weaponized
by our own federal government and the
dossier author Christopher Steele I
thought for our nationals words supposed
to Lauren supposed to influence our
elections anyway
steel fed his tainted propaganda with
multiple individuals inside the Obama
administration high-ranking DOJ of
Oh Bruce or well he warned everybody in
the DOJ and the FBI that steel was being
funded by the Clinton campaign she was
paying for all of it and that is
information her information she paid for
was unverified that steel hated Trump
and Hillary paid for it that was August
of 2016
investigative reporter John Solomon from
the hill he'll join us in a minute with
much more breaking news reporting that
the Deputy Assistant Secretary of State
Kathleen CAV elec well documented that
Steel's research was all political there
was an end date he had an election day
deadline ten days later October 21st Oh
Jim Comey mr. Jim 2016 signed off on the
first FISA application against Carter
Paige swearing that steel was reliable
and accurate and that he verified the
bulk of that information which was
Hillary's bought and paid for Russian
lies remember that's on top of the FISA
application
he says the verified application the
words are right on top and down tonight
we have brand-new just released
handwritten documents uncovered by John
Solomon the investigative reporter
showing the State Department official
Kathleen CAV elec actually sounded the
alarm about steel to the high-ranking
members of the FBI Jim Comey's FBI over
a multitude of issues all before the
first FISA application went in not only
did she report the partisan nature of
Steel's research but also accused him of
giving the government blatantly false
information and also leaking his
material to the New York Times and The
Washington Post all too happy to of
course print it she raised all of these
damning concerns well before Christopher
Steele was the centerpiece of the first
FISA warrant request or application
against Trump campaign associate Carter
page thus giving a backdoor into all
things Trump all things world Trump all
things Trump campaign and according to
Salomon well breaking just minutes ago
congressman mark meadows confirming this
information was in fact transmitted to
the FBI Wow me
that's why the self-aggrandizing Patriot
Jim Comey is trying hard to reshape the
narrative and yet another public
appearance on fake news CNN earlier
tonight take a look
New York Times reported that the FBI
sent an investigator posing as an
assistant to meet with a trump a george
papadapolis in 2016
does that qua that qualify as spying
yeah I'm not gonna comment on a
particular investigative step because
that's for the bureau to do and I'm not
in the government any longer but the FBI
doesn't spy to begin with the FBI
investigates the the Inspector General
the Attorney General they're obviously
now looking into the origins of the
investigation it's the president and his
campaign are you confident you did
everything by the book and that the FBI
the people around you did everything by
the book yes no doesn't no doubt in my
mind but that doesn't mean I'm against
review of it that's totally funny you
think the Inspector General will find
nothing inappropriate I don't think so
at least they're not that I know of but
if they do they do and they should be
transparent about it hey Jimbo you
signed a FISA application to spy on
Carter page and the entire Trump
campaign by the way I've warned you
before you know what Jim you have the
right to remain silent
I'd start using that right